hello freak [ __ ] I know I'm the other
I have a thing where I go I guess quick
like click click click click click and
then I let myself hang from my neck and
the Moy it's just like that just like
that see how that guy's just sitting
there reading the magazine yeah and you
can adjust that so there's a little
chord stuff to see in this photo but
there's a chord you pull sort of like a
plunger on those old-school toilets you
pull that click click click click click
click click see how he's pulling it
right there and then you just relax and
you just got to learn how to go with it
and sort of relax and it feels weird at
first there's a lot of pressure but it's
pulling your neck literally pulling your
neck you can feel sometimes when I'm
really relaxed I feel like pop I feel
like something pop a little tissue
separations in there does it have do you
feel that it's gotten better long-term
oh yeah for sure and it feels like
really relaxing like after it's over I
feel like I feel like it just takes a
weight off you know sure I think there's
a tremendous and I think sitting is
terrible these seats that we're in right
now are exceptional because their
economic chair if you use it right if
you use them right yeah I'm pretty
cautious about sitting up straight but
from back injuries I've been very very
cautious about working out all the
muscles around my back you know didn't
really I just worked out and I figure
those things take care of themselves now
a treat them is like just like brushing
my teeth like my spinal column and all
those supporting muscles in the spine
does a huge they need they need to be
exercised and especially if you do
anything like you guys pack out a lot of
weight yeah that's a big one and I fans
where he feels that a different when he
had sciatica right that's lower that's a
lump yeah that was a different thing but
he he he knows he like traces that to a
specific animal that he's packing out
yeah makes sense because sciatica is
what sciatica is is a disc that's
bulging meaning the disc the soft tissue
in between the two hard bones is pushing
out and it's pressing up against the
nerve and it causes pain that shoots
down your ass and your lower legs and a
lot of people don't even
recognize it as a lower-back issue
because maybe their back is not really
that painful but the leg and the ass is
painful yeah what the [ __ ] is going on
here I had a similar issue with my neck
where was pushing on my ulnar nerve and
I was getting this elbow pain and I was
like [ __ ] this really hurts like down my
arm and in the back of my tricep and
then I started getting numbness in my
fingers and that's when I started
figuring out what was going on then I
went to a doctor I went to a
chiropractor first was a [ __ ] giant
mistake I spent a year but do not
believe in chiropractors I don't believe
in chiropractors at all
I think it's 98% horse [ __ ] that's what
I think
and I'm I don't know but I think
chiropractors that are smart they
incorporate things that I think are
beneficial cold laser massage a lot of
different things but I think that
manipulation that they do you have like
some sort of significant scoliosis or
something they're attempting to slowly
put back into position I think most of
the time is just pop at your neck and it
just feels good but I just like in an
immediate sense I went to a guy that's a
very nice guy and he was trying to tell
me that I didn't have a bulging disc
because he was pushing down atop my head
and it didn't hurt I'm like okay so I
was listening to him I listened to this
guy for like a [ __ ] year I had
treatment with him
and I still have these neck problems and
back problems and finally I got an MRI
like a you got a bulging disc and I
remember being angry I remember being
angry because I was angry that I was
being treated by someone who was a
professional that really didn't know
what the [ __ ] they were talking yeah and
they were treating something that was a
significant issue that I was
experiencing a real deterioration of my
function pain as I wasn't able to do
jujitsu correctly there's a lot of a lot
of problems that I was dealing with I
was like well what the [ __ ] is this like
how and then I started talking to
doctors about it and when you have a
bulging disc man they want to cut you
open like like you're a pinata and you
got gold and saw that a thing that my
bro is talking about is the per seat
he's very nervous about a procedure that
he could or could not do
[Applause]
[Music]